hi i'm marlon class and i want to send  huge congratulations to uk teacher jamie  frost  who's a finalist for the global teacher  prize 2020.  jamie is an incredible achievement to  have been chosen from over 12 000  nominations and applications from across  the world your free website  dr frost maths became a lifeline for  students all over the world who were  learning in lockdown  now more than ever i strongly believe  that we must back  teachers like you jamie teachers  everywhere should be applauded for their  hard work  compassion and determination to keep  young people learning during covid  lockdown and beyond supporting teachers  as they continue to inspire  even as the world shifts under their  feet isn't just the right thing to do  it's the wellspring of our future thank  you